considera la curva definida por la
ecuación x + ya la cuarta más 6x igual a
7 se puede mostrar que esta derivada de
ye con respecto a x es igual a menos 2
por x 3 entre 4 x al cubo esto lo
podemos comprobar con una derivación
implícita y despejar la derivada de ie
con respecto a x como lo hemos hecho en
otros vídeos escribe la ecuación de la
recta horizontal que está en gente a la
curva y está arriba del eje x pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
vamos a asegurarnos de que comprendemos
lo que está pasando aquí dibujamos un
diagrama aquí está el eje y y aquí el
eje x no sabemos exactamente cómo es
esta curva pero podemos imaginar
cualquier tipo de curva cerrada que se
vea así vamos a tener dos rectas
tangentes que son horizontales la que
está aquí y la que está acá nos piden la
recta tangente horizontal que está
arriba del eje x así que nos interesa la
recta de arriba que es lo que se debe
cumplir para que una recta sea tangente
y horizontal pues que deje de x
de este punto sea igual a cero esto se
cumple para estos dos puntos en el
enunciado nos dicen que deje de x es
igual a menos 2 por x 3 entre 4 y al
cubo cuándo será esto igual a 0 cuando
el numerador sea igual a 0 y el
denominador sea diferente de 0 cuando es
0 el numerador cuando x es igual a menos
tres cuando x es igual a menos 3 deje de
x es igual a 0
qué valor corresponde ayer cuando x es
igual a menos 3 y la ecuación que nos
piden será igual a ese valor de iu y
para encontrar ese valor vamos a
sustituir x igual a menos 3 en la
ecuación original y despejamos y lo
hacemos y nos queda menos 3 al cuadrado
más a la cuarta más 6 x menos 3 igual a
7 esto es 9 esto es menos 18 y nos queda
ya a la cuarta menos 9 es igual a 7
sumamos 9 a ambos lados y nos queda ya a
la cuarta igual a 16 y esto nos da más
menos 2
que tenemos dos rectas horizontales una
igualados y otra es igual a menos dos
pero nos piden la recta horizontal
tangente que está arriba del eje que es
esta de acá y igualados con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo